Seção 9 de Dom Casmurro.
Esta é uma gravação LibriVox. Todas as gravações LibriVox estão em domínio público. Para mais informações, ou para ser um voluntário, por favor visite: librivox.org.
Gravado por Jane Nogueira.
Dom Casmurro, de Joaquim Maria Machado de Assis.
Capítulos XLI a XLV.
Capítulo XLI A audiência secreta
O resto fez-me ficar mais algum tempo, no corredor, pensando. Vi entrar o Dr. João da Costa, e preparou-se logo o voltarete do costume. Minha mãe saiu da sala, e, dando comigo, perguntou se acompanhara Capitu.
— Não, senhora, ela foi só.
E quase investindo para ela:
— Mamãe, eu queria dizer-lhe uma coisa.
— Que é?
Toda assustada, quis saber o que é que me doía, se a cabeça, se o peito, se o estômago, e apalpava-me a testa para ver se tinha febre.
— Não tenho nada, não, senhora.
— Mas então que é?
— É uma coisa, mamãe... Mas, escute, olhe, é melhor depois do chá; logo... Não é nada mau; mamãe assusta-se por tudo; não é coisa de cuidado.
— Não é moléstia?
— Não, senhora.
— É, isso é volta de constipação. Disfarças para não tomar suadouro, mas tu estás constipado; conhece-se pela voz.
Tentei rir, para mostrar que não tinha nada. Nem por isso permitiu adiar a confidência; pegou em mim, levou-me ao quarto dela, acendeu vela, e ordenou-me que lhe dissesse tudo. Então eu perguntei-lhe, para principiar, quando é que ia para o seminário.
— Agora só para o ano, depois das férias.
— Vou... para ficar?
— Como ficar?
— Não volto para casa?
— Voltas aos sábados e pelas férias; é melhor. Quando te ordenares padre, vens morar comigo.
Enxuguei os olhos e o nariz. Ela afagou-me, depois quis repreender-me, mas creio que a voz lhe tremia, e pareceu-me que tinha os olhos úmidos. Disse-lhe que também sentia a nossa separação. Negou que fosse separação; era só alguma ausência, por causa dos estudos; só os primeiros dias. Em pouco tempo eu me acostumaria aos companheiros e aos mestres, e acabaria gostando de viver com eles.
— Eu só gosto de mamãe.
Não houve cálculo nesta palavra, mas estimei dizê-la, por fazer crer que ela era a minha única afeição; desviava as suspeitas de cima de Capitu. Quantas intenções viciosas há assim que embarcam, a meio caminho, numa frase inocente e pura! Chega a fazer suspeitar que a mentira é, muita vez, tão involuntária como a transpiração.
Por outro lado, leitor amigo, nota que eu queria desviar as suspeitas de cima de Capitu, quando havia chamado minha mãe justamente para confirmá-las; mas as contradições são deste mundo. A verdade é que minha mãe era cândida como a primeira aurora, anterior ao primeiro pecado; nem por simples intuição era capaz de deduzir uma coisa de outra, isto é, não concluiria da minha repentina oposição que eu andasse em segredinhos com Capitu, como lhe dissera José Dias.
Calou-se durante alguns instantes; depois replicou-me sem imposição nem autoridade, o que me veio animando à resistência. Daí o falar-lhe na vocação que se discutira naquela tarde, e que eu confessei não sentir em mim.
— Mas tu gostavas tanto de ser padre, disse ela; não te lembras que até pedias para ir ver sair os seminaristas de São José, com as suas batinas? Em casa, quando José Dias te chamava Reverendíssimo, tu rias com tanto gosto! Como é que agora?... Não creio, não, Bentinho. E depois... Vocação? Mas a vocação vem com o costume, continuou repetindo as reflexões que ouvira ao meu professor de latim.
Como eu buscasse contestá-la, repreendeu-me sem aspereza, mas com alguma força, e eu tornei ao filho submisso que era. Depois, ainda falou gravemente e longamente sobre a promessa que fizera; não me disse as circunstâncias, nem a ocasião, nem os motivos dela, coisas que só vim a saber mais tarde. Afirmou o principal, isto é, que a havia de cumprir, em pagamento a Deus.
— Nosso Senhor me acudiu, salvando a tua existência, não lhe hei de mentir nem faltar, Bentinho; são coisas que não se fazem sem pecado, e Deus, que é grande e poderoso, não me deixaria assim, não, Bentinho; eu sei que seria castigada e bem castigada. Ser padre é bom e santo; você conhece muitos, como o Padre Cabral, que vive tão feliz com a irmã; um tio meu também foi padre, e escapou de ser bispo, dizem... Deixa de manha, Bentinho.
Creio que os olhos que lhe deitei foram tão queixosos, que ela emendou logo a palavra, manha, não, não podia ser manha, sabia muito bem que eu era amigo dela, e não seria capaz de fingir um sentimento que não tivesse. Moleza é o que queria dizer, que me deixasse de moleza, que me fizesse homem e obedecesse ao que cumpria, em benefício dela e para bem da minha alma. Todas essas coisas e outras foram ditas um pouco atropeladamente, e a voz não lhe saía clara, mas velada e esganada.
Vi que a emoção dela era outra vez grande, mas não recuava dos seus propósitos, e aventurei-me a perguntar-lhe:
— E se mamãe pedisse a Deus que a dispensasse da promessa?
— Não, não peço. Estás tonto, Bentinho? E como havia de saber que Deus me dispensava?
— Talvez em sonho; eu sonho às vezes com anjos e santos.
— Também eu, meu filho; mas é inútil... Vamos, é tarde; vamos para a sala. Está entendido: no primeiro ou no segundo mês do ano que vem, irás para o seminário. O que eu quero é que saibas bem os livros que estás estudando; é bonito, não só para ti, como para o Padre Cabral. No seminário há interesse em conhecer-te, porque o Padre Cabral fala de ti com entusiasmo.
Caminhou para a porta, saímos ambos. Antes de sair, voltou-se para mim, e quase a vi saltar-me ao colo e dizer-me que não seria padre. Este era já o seu desejo íntimo, à proporção que se aproximava o tempo. Quisera um modo de pagar a dívida contraída, outra moeda, que valesse tanto ou mais, e não achava nenhuma.
Capítulo XLII Capitu refletindo
No dia seguinte fui à casa vizinha, logo que pude. Capitu despedia-se de duas amigas que tinham ido visitá-la, Paula e Sancha, companheiras de colégio, aquela de quinze, esta de dezessete anos, a primeira filha de um médico, a segunda de um comerciante de objetos americanos. Estava abatida, trazia um lenço atado na cabeça; a mãe contou-me que fora excesso de leitura na véspera, antes e depois do chá, na sala e na cama, até muito depois da meia-noite, e com lamparina...
— Se eu acendesse vela, mamãe zangava-se. Já estou boa.
E como desatasse o lenço, a mãe disse-lhe timidamente que era melhor atá-lo, mas Capitu respondeu que não era preciso, estava boa.
Ficamos sós na sala; Capitu confirmou a narração da mãe, acrescentando que passara mal por causa do que ouvira em minha casa. Também eu lhe contei o que se dera comigo, a entrevista com minha mãe, as minhas súplicas, as lágrimas dela, e por fim as últimas respostas decisivas: dentro de dois ou três meses iria para o seminário. Que faríamos agora? Capitu ouvia-me com atenção sôfrega, depois sombria; quando acabei, respirava a custo, como prestes a estalar de cólera, mas conteve-se.
Há tanto tempo que isto sucedeu que não posso dizer com segurança se chorou deveras, ou se somente enxugou os olhos; cuido que os enxugou somente. Vendo-lhe o gesto, peguei-lhe na mão para animá-la, mas também eu precisava ser animado. Caímos no canapé, e ficamos a olhar para o ar. Minto; ela olhava para o chão. Fiz o mesmo, logo que a vi assim...
Mas eu creio que Capitu olhava para dentro de si mesma, enquanto que eu fitava deveras o chão, o roído das fendas, duas moscas andando e um pé de cadeira lascado. Era pouco, mas distraía-me da aflição. Quando tornei a olhar para Capitu, vi que não se mexia, e fiquei com tal medo que a sacudi brandamente. Capitu tornou cá fora e pediu-me que outra vez lhe contasse o que se passara com minha mãe. Satisfi-la, atenuando o texto desta vez, para não amofiná-la.
Não me chames dissimulado, chama-me compassivo; é certo que receava perder Capitu, se lhe morressem as esperanças todas, mas doía-me vê-la padecer. Agora, a verdade última, a verdade das verdades, é que já me arrependia de haver falado a minha mãe, antes de qualquer trabalho efetivo por parte de José Dias; examinando bem, não quisera ter ouvido um desengano que eu reputava certo, ainda que demorado. Capitu refletia, refletia, refletia...
Capítulo XLIII Você tem medo?
De repente, cessando a reflexão, fitou em mim os olhos de ressaca, e perguntou-me se tinha medo.
— Medo?
— Sim, pergunto se você tem medo.
— Medo de quê?
— Medo de apanhar, de ser preso, de brigar, de andar, de trabalhar...
Não entendi. Se ela tem dito simplesmente: “Vamos embora!” pode ser que eu obedecesse ou não; em todo caso, entenderia. Mas aquela pergunta assim, vaga e solta, não pude atinar o que era.
— Mas... não entendo. De apanhar?
— Sim.
— Apanhar de quem? Quem é que me dá pancada?
Capitu fez um gesto de impaciência. Os olhos de ressaca não se mexiam e pareciam crescer. Sem saber de mim, e não querendo interrogá-la novamente, entrei a cogitar donde me viriam pancadas, e por que, e também por que é que seria preso, e quem é que me havia de prender. Valha-me Deus! vi de imaginação o aljube, uma casa escura e infecta. Também vi a presiganga, o quartel dos Barbonos e a Casa de Correção.
Todas essas belas instituições sociais me envolviam no seu mistério, sem que os olhos de ressaca de Capitu deixassem de crescer para mim, a tal ponto que as fizeram esquecer de todo. O erro de Capitu foi não deixá-los crescer infinitamente, antes diminuir até as dimensões normais, e dar-lhes o movimento do costume. Capitu tornou ao que era, disse-me que estava brincando, não precisava afligir-me, e, com um gesto cheio de graça, bateu-me na cara, sorrindo, e disse:
— Medroso!
— Eu? Mas...
— Não é nada, Bentinho. Pois quem é que há de dar pancada ou prender você? Desculpe, que eu hoje estou meia maluca; quero brincar, e...
— Não, Capitu; você não está brincando; nesta ocasião, nenhum de nós tem vontade de brincar.
— Tem razão, foi só maluquice; até logo.
— Como até logo?
— Está-me voltando a dor de cabeça; vou botar uma rodela de limão nas fontes.
Fez o que disse, e atou o lenço outra vez na testa. Em seguida, acompanhou-me ao quintal para se despedir de mim; mas, ainda aí nos detivemos por alguns minutos, sentados sobre a borda do poço. Ventava, o céu estava coberto. Capitu falou novamente da nossa separação, como de um fato certo e definitivo, por mais que eu, receoso disso mesmo, buscasse agora razões para animá-la. Capitu, quando não falava, riscava no chão, com um pedaço de taquara, narizes e perfis.
Desde que se metera a desenhar, era uma das suas diversões; tudo lhe servia de papel e lápis. Como me lembrassem os nossos nomes abertos por ela no muro, quis fazer o mesmo no chão, e pedi-lhe a taquara. Não me ouviu ou não me atendeu.
Capítulo XLIV O primeiro filho
— Dê cá, deixe escrever uma coisa.
Capitu olhou para mim, mas de um modo que me fez lembrar a definição de José Dias, oblíquo e dissimulado; levantou o olhar, sem levantar os olhos. A voz, um tanto sumida, perguntou-me:
— Diga-me uma coisa, mas fale verdade, não quero disfarce; há de responder com o coração na mão.
— Que é? Diga.
— Se você tivesse de escolher entre mim e sua mãe, a quem é que escolhia?
— Eu?
Fez-me sinal que sim.
— Eu escolhia... mas para que escolher? Mamãe não é capaz de me perguntar isso.
— Pois sim, mas eu pergunto. Suponha você que está no seminário e recebe a notícia de que eu vou morrer...
— Não diga isso!
— ...Ou que me mato de saudades, se você não vier logo, e sua mãe não quiser que você venha, diga-me, você vem?
— Venho.
— Contra a ordem de sua mãe?
— Contra a ordem de mamãe.
— Você deixa seminário, deixa sua mãe, deixa tudo, para me ver morrer?
— Não fale em morrer, Capitu!
Capitu teve um risinho descorado e incrédulo, e com a taquara escreveu uma palavra no chão; inclinei-me e li: mentiroso.
Era tão estranho tudo aquilo, que não achei resposta. Não atinava com a razão do escrito, como não atinava com a do falado. Se me acudisse ali uma injúria grande ou pequena, é possível que a escrevesse também, com a mesma taquara, mas não me lembrava nada. Tinha a cabeça vazia. Ao mesmo tempo tomei-me de receio de que alguém nos pudesse ouvir ou ler. Quem, se éramos sós? D. Fortunata chegara uma vez à porta da casa, mas entrou logo depois. A solidão era completa.
Lembra-me que umas andorinhas passaram por cima do quintal e foram para os lados do morro de Santa Teresa; ninguém mais. Ao longe, vozes vagas e confusas, na rua um tropel de bestas, do lado da casa o chilrear dos passarinhos do Pádua. Nada mais, ou somente este fenômeno curioso, que o nome escrito por ela não só me espiava do chão com gesto escarninho, mas até me pareceu que repercutia no ar.
Tive então uma ideia ruim; disse-lhe que, afinal de contas, a vida de padre não era má, e eu podia aceitá-la sem grande pena. Como desforço, era pueril; mas eu sentia a secreta esperança de vê-la atirar-se a mim lavada em lágrimas. Capitu limitou-se a arregalar muito os olhos, e acabou por dizer:
— Padre é bom, não há dúvida; melhor que padre só cônego, por causa das meias roxas. O roxo é cor muito bonita. Pensando bem, é melhor cônego.
— Mas não se pode ser cônego sem ser primeiramente padre, disse-lhe eu mordendo os beiços.
— Bem; comece pelas meias pretas, depois virão as roxas. O que eu não quero perder é sua missa nova; avise-me a tempo para fazer um vestido à moda, saia-balão e babados grandes... Mas talvez nesse tempo a moda seja outra. A igreja há de ser grande, Carmo ou São Francisco.
— Ou Candelária.
— Candelária também. Qualquer serve, contanto que eu ouça a missa nova. Hei de fazer um figurão. Muita gente há de perguntar: “Quem é aquela moça faceira que ali está com um vestido tão bonito?”
— “Aquela é D. Capitolina, uma moça que morou na Rua de Matacavalos...”
— Que morou? Você vai mudar-se?
— Quem sabe onde é que há de morar amanhã? disse ela com um tom leve de melancolia; mas, tornando logo ao sarcasmo: E você no altar, metido na alva, com a capa de ouro por cima, cantando... Pater noster...
Ah! como eu sinto não ser poeta romântico para dizer que isto era um duelo de ironias! Contaria os meus botes e os dela, a graça de um e a prontidão de outro, e o sangue correndo, e o furor na alma, até ao meu golpe final que foi este:
— Pois, sim, Capitu, você ouvirá a minha missa nova, mas com uma condição.
Ao que ela respondeu:
— Vossa Reverendíssima pode falar.
— Promete uma coisa?
— Que é?
— Diga se promete.
— Não sabendo o que é, não prometo.
— A falar verdade são duas coisas, continuei eu, por haver-me acudido outra ideia.
— Duas? Diga quais são.
— A primeira é que só se há de confessar comigo, para eu lhe dar a penitência e a absolvição. A segunda é que...
— A primeira está prometida, disse ela vendo-me hesitar, e acrescentou que esperava a segunda.
Palavra que me custou, e antes não me chegasse a sair da boca; não ouviria o que ouvi, e não escreveria aqui uma coisa que vai talvez achar incrédulos.
— A segunda... sim... é que... Promete-me que seja eu o padre que case você?
— Que me case? disse ela um tanto comovida.
Logo depois fez descair os lábios, e abanou a cabeça. Não, Bentinho, disse, seria esperar muito tempo; você não vai ser padre já amanhã, leva muitos anos...
— Olhe, prometo outra coisa; prometo que há de batizar o meu primeiro filho.
Capítulo XLV Abane a cabeça, leitor
Abane a cabeça, leitor; faça todos os gestos de incredulidade. Chegue a deitar fora este livro, se o tédio já o não obrigou a isso antes; tudo é possível. Mas, se o não fez antes e só agora, fio que torne a pegar do livro e que o abra na mesma página, sem crer por isso na veracidade do autor. Todavia, não há nada mais exato. Foi assim mesmo que Capitu falou, com tais palavras e maneiras. Falou do primeiro filho, como se fosse a primeira boneca.
Quanto ao meu espanto, se também foi grande, veio de mistura com uma sensação esquisita. Percorreu-me um fluido. Aquela ameaça de um primeiro filho, o primeiro filho de Capitu, o casamento dela com outro, portanto, a separação absoluta, a perda, a aniquilação, tudo isso produzia um tal efeito, que não achei palavra nem gesto; fiquei estúpido. Capitu sorria; eu via o primeiro filho brincando no chão...
Fim da seção 9.
Gravado por Jane Nogueira.